[Music]
dink-dink y'all get to keep going
[Music]
Squarespace is the sponsor for today's
podcast start your website today with
Squarespace for the squarespace.com
slash in Julian save 10% on your first
purchase of a web server domain amazing
website design easy process Keanu Reeves
uses it 24/7 customer support check it
out
also guys me undies it's that time of
year okay you got to get your Christmas
gifts your holiday gifts for your
friends your loved ones me and these is
a perfect holiday gift it really is so
go to meet undies calm /out and Julian
get 15% off your first pair of free
shipping at a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee okay get some
festive underwear do it just do it
thank you sponsors hi Doolin hi how you
doing I'm rolling baby I'm doing great
what does that mean I'm not operating on
all cylinders today I feel that I
understand
I stayed up until 7:00 a.m. oh my god
I hope my mom is not watching
it's past my bedtime oh you stayed up so
Lea and I went to bed and watched old
episodes of ancient aliens oh you
remember seeing on the TV when I came to
that they're just so good I don't know I
just like how they end every episode
with like that's what ancient alien
theorists believe and you're like okay I
mean you can't argue with what someone
else believes some guy thinks all of
this so roll credits okay they have all
these theories they tell all these
stories and like and that's what one
person thinks thanks for watching based
on the thoughts of a guy they just say
ancient alien theorists I'm like alright
yes no that's covering their own ass
can't argue with what someone else
thinks I quite literally disagree I mean
you can't you can argue it but I mean I
can't be like you don't think that I
disagree okay I disagree with hey well
you know the job phone no I did I played
video games are streaming for
like 10 hours it was it was a degenerate
hours it was good though it was fun we
played I played mostly talk all the last
night but we play life is strange this
week which late I wanted to talk about
the podcast but I'll do in the second
half because I don't want like the whole
thing to be spoiler alert boy alert so
you guys are gonna play life is strange
I don't want to spoil it so we'll spoil
it at the end then you can just boil it
later in the podcast really yes yeah but
no we played a lot of talk up honestly
that game is it's so much fun and it's
fun to drink and play to be honest yeah
I don't know how you do that well I just
pour it into my glass and I take a sip
I'm not asking how you drink when I put
my hands on the keyboard and mouse and
that goal that game is not for me
you ever play a video game and you're
just like oh this is not for me
oh yeah it's not for me yeah that's that
game for me not for me that's fine
that's the beauty of video game just
like you and subnautica when are you
gonna finish subnautica I'll finish it
it's like the greatest like
single-player PC game on the steam in my
opinion you can't argue with it because
it's my opinion and it's what I think I
disagree with we've already established
that you're not allowed to disagree that
I in fact think that I just agree with
mmhmm
Sbrocco is not the best thing alert it's
pretty good what do you say that's good
stories afraid of the ocean and open why
is that great
it's bad I don't think it's bad I just
like here's the thing like when we when
we played Minecraft a lot like I was in
Conan 2 which both games are adding
things and we can go back to them at any
point but um you're like I sort of get
in this frame of mind of like we're
working on these projects you know we
gotta we gotta get this done we gotta
collect the materials we you know this
and that
and I think right now I'm just not in
that gaming space of like gaming
headspace kind of you know like I'm I'm
100% are caught right now mm-hm
but it's it feels good to be completely
just in a video game like I'm just oh
this girl's online I'm so caught up in
it I can't stop playing
it's a good time it's a good time
remember when I got to bed the other
night after playing it for like a lunch
hours and we're going to sleep and I was
like babe I want to go by dark okay I'm
trading sleep for it yes you got it you
got to control it a little bit you know
you can't be getting no sleep because
you staying up all night and then waking
up and then not getting any semi overly
attached our cosplayer is talk of like
hey Julian I gotta wake up early in the
morning you gotta balance maybe maybe
yeah well anyway I'm enjoying it the end
you doing okay I'm trying just try my
best that's all I can do it's really
hard to be drunk and play a first-person
shooter game I just know it is hard I
died a lot oh no oh no but it makes it
like the thing about a game like that is
it doesn't it's more than meets the eye
in so many ways but the most like
valuable of those ways is like it's a
hilarious game and hilarious situations
happen it's like pub G you know the way
like we would play a long game of pub G
and it within the 35 minute match there
are moments that you can just like sort
of role play a little bit you know
you're like kind of our peeing and
there's your friends and everyone's like
joking then like things happen in the
game that are kind of funky and I think
tarkov is exactly the same why you
laughing I'm laughing because the other
day I was using the guild finder and the
other Scrolls and there's legit like
role-playing guilds we're a role-playing
guild like come in here and act like a
Khajiit yeah that's some G by the way
are cats
I would roleplay as a Khajiit they dug
like this one this one so hey that's
what they talking like boys chatting so
yeah I've literally like tonight so
obviously most of you guys know but like
mo more often than not at night we'll
play video games like that's we used to
like watch shows watch TV and I feel
like now we'll go we'll sit
play video games and so Julian will play
tarkov and then I'll play the Elder
Scrolls online and we'll play pubs you
together and yeah story games together
yeah and so it was like a Saturday night
or something and I was on the Elder
Scrolls and I was playing in a group and
then you can just be I was doing a
dungeon so I was using a queue finder to
queue up with random other people and
then people can be on their mics if they
want or not yeah and those guys just in
the chat just talking about how he's
drunk and he's drinking but he's
speaking as Akashi so he's like this one
is going to get another drink wait for
me no you did not you did not boy you
did not just do that then he comes back
and he's like this one does not know the
mechanics with this dungeon will you
please tell me and I'm like look I don't
want to yuck you're young you know but
like it's just kind of freaking me out
man it's actually hilarious it's like
there's a whole guild of people to do
that but it's the thought what's funny
to me about roleplay like that and this
and this is not a slam on it at all like
it's [ __ ] do whatever makes you happy
but it's just funny to me to think about
people role playing in a video game like
that but they're not streaming it it's
just like what they want to do you know
because we're all play blew up in the
last year on Twitch with like GTA and
like now red dead and it's funny because
you watch people roleplay and it's
largely like some of the most
entertaining [ __ ] on Twitch because
you're watching this character being
created from your eyes our friend Jeff
did for a while right but the
understanding is that everyone on that
server is also role-playing yes the
people that are playing the Elder
Scrolls online and I imagine other games
as well that are just so in love with
some of the characters that they
themselves want to be them are
role-playing in a world where everyone
else is just playing the game it's like
if you went on destiny or something
where there's like other people and like
one person is just like hardcore
role-playing with the voice guy thing
like if you had to group up with them
and then he just like won't drop it at
all he's just he's going got these
characters a cat and he's
like making a ducat emotes and stuff you
know what that is that's balls to the
wall that's like they take it seriously
say I'm not writing yuck you're young
like that's really cool for you but like
it makes it difficult for us to work
together right now
I kind of want to roleplay as what I
don't know in what in tarkov yeah we'll
had this idea there's a map called
interchange where it's a mall it's like
a defunct old mall and it's you know
it's combat zone now but we'll thought
it would be so funny if he was like if
talk I've ever launches our P servers
I'm going to create one where everyone's
a scab and working at a shop in the mall
yeah but no I mean I think I think like
it's interesting because role play blew
up under the genre of role play
you're watching RP right you see someone
or most times they don't have their face
cam on but you hear someone role playing
as a character in this game where other
people are doing the same they're
streaming it but like you'd like in
games we've you know there's been role
play like you know that just passively
happens yeah you know and I think games
that allow for that and also add to it
with the funny moments with the
characters and especially oh my god the
tag lines in the Russian tag lines and
the American tag lines like they have
these preset lines that you can like you
know and you have a little stuff down
and when you squeeze it and it says
something it's like that's what you're
doing so it makes for some really really
funny sure I like the idea of somebody
working a nine-to-five coming home
taking their shoes off and turning on
their Xbox and getting in there there's
random tension and saying this one this
one won't be right back I have to get
another drink as they make their cat do
a cat emote I love it though that's like
it's the world of games every time
that's his me time yeah dude anything's
possible speaking of that though like
there's and now we're in the world where
VR really does feel super [ __ ]
immersive and it does feel like a whole
nother world where you're kind of like
plugging in to the matrix a little bit
there's this game coming out
I think it's half-life alex is what the
name of its called and i watch the
trailer for it and i was like oh my god
I I'm gonna play that game in VR and I'm
gonna feel completely in this like you
know how I was playing that game super
hot were you're the action here on your
shooting that's very like Arkady right
because you're like shooting the bad
guys and you're dodging bullets and
whatever this one is like a full-on like
RPG first-person game with a story and
you're like in there the whole time and
PR fighting the bad guys and doing this
really cool and for me that's like dude
when I was a kid I would never have
dreamed that would have been a thing
that you can put on your head and then
you're in it yeah my brother well my
brother had won a grey gameboy that I
would steal when he was I'm brand I
played Tetris on it yeah yeah it's very
hard for me to imagine putting something
on my head and playing a holster yeah
and just feeling so involved in the game
it's a really cool thing what this I got
a case falling off and she's happy she's
a cookie she's a cookie but anyway you
so you're not gonna role play in tarkov
no well you guys do went in that
classroom that one time we did Labs room
all fun and games so money old guys
though
no it's still funny games I got my first
I got my first haircut and not my
hairdressers spot and like many men
that's everything Beach because you
don't want to talk about it before you
say anything I have not had a
professional touch my hair since your
hairdresser did my hair in 2017 yeah no
one has cut my hair dyed my hair done
anything in my hair I definitely feel
like at some point I'm gonna have to do
something twigs it's like really long
and heavy yeah but like I know what it
feels like when you loyalty a
hairdresser yeah and then the cuz rough
yeah I can't care of a sick dog yeah
yeah he's got some you know stuff going
on he can't work right now but um and
like he's been my favorite like hair
stylist I could have ever imagined
having and I I never really have had
like one barber or hair stylist until
met him and this was like when I had
long hair I'm going to with different
hair dress oh my god well I want to talk
about this experience because this is
something that like it's first of all I
feel like a lot of people can relate to
right like you have your your spot or
your person but you got to get your
haircuts your hair and then there comes
a time where you either need a haircut
and they can't do it or something
happens and there's a breakup or
whatever you know it's like between it's
an intense thing there's like a whole
Seinfeld episode about it it's really
funny but anyway I was like okay I need
to cut my hair because I was getting to
the point where it was about like I
think close to two months till I go so
my since I got my hair cut and you know
how I get you haven't seen it for a long
time because I've been getting my hair
cut so well often there's all of a
sudden just take out your clippers and
shave your head yeah I get like neurotic
when my hair gets past a certain point
of length which I still don't know how I
grew my hair all the way out I don't
know how I did that but anyway it was
getting the point where was driving me
like crazy it was uncomfortable I hated
how I looked sounds like you know what
Jenna I think I just got to go to like
one of these little chains and go get my
hair cut and get a fade because I'm
losing my mind so I did and there's
nothing really crazy that happened like
it was just a very minded me how lucky I
am to have that I like the hair stylist
I have and Rothen like the situation
where someone knows what haircut you
like and you don't have to like meet a
new person every time you think that
wouldn't be fun I don't I don't relish
that but you know I overall okay haircut
I kind of had to fix some of it when I
got home yeah you did I didn't feel very
heard I hate that yeah and I you know I
thought to myself is this really worth
you know telling her and she's wrong and
I want I want this a different way
because in general I am the type of
person who you know I'll stick up for
that I'll be like yeah you know I know
I'm not trying to disrespect or anything
but I actually want this when you're
doing it wrong or just because I think
number you know number one is honesty
right and in a service worse like you
know someone's situation worse ones
providing a service it's
their best interest to want to please
you so you want to help them do that so
I was thinking about self I was like
dude I don't really think she's doing
for listening to what I want and she's
doing it the wrong way and I've actually
never seen someone do it this way
oh no but I'm like I just gotta want to
get out of here
and you just needed it cut I just need a
little thing gonna go back to rob and
the second he's available yeah and it's
the size wasn't worth the fight I wasn't
worth it the sides in the back like not
the top left the top but yeah I was like
I don't know it was that I wanted it to
be a little different and I the small
talk was kind of weird to hate that she
was like what are you up to today and I
was like oh I was just working because I
edited that day I was like yeah I was
just working she was like all your
running errands sounds like no no it was
a weird assumption of work I was working
I was working okay no I mean errands you
you know and then she was like something
about the weather and I was like yeah
I've really been enjoying the cold
weather and she was like yeah that's hot
today that's like what no it's raining
like wind or wheat having a conversation
and then she was doing the the buzzer
one of the small ones where you do like
the neck and so it was the loudest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard
and she's buzzing right by my ear and
asking me questions I can hear you so
loud I'm pretty sure it was when I used
to live in Santa Monica or something
there was a hairdresser close to where
one of the places I used to live mm-hmm
where it was a barber shop mm-hmm and he
was really highly rated like on Yelp
because he didn't speak to anyone he all
of his reviews were literally like yeah
it's got like totally fine haircut like
it's something wasn't that the one I
went through I'm pretty sure what was
the one yeah all his reviews are like he
doesn't talk that's one in five stars
that's why I went there
yeah yeah it was all it was I remember
exactly where it is it was literally on
Bundy and Wilshire he had five star
reviews not because he was like the
world's greatest barber because he
didn't say anything to you yeah I I was
looking up barbers that's back when I
like buzz my head and did like the
member take not imagine building your
clientele just because you don't say
anything to them
a lot of people from people that just
don't want to make sauce a lot of people
like that I mean they introduced that
whole option on uber right where you
don't want to talk you say leave me
alone there's like a button you press oh
yeah I mean for people that have any
type of social anxiety it's even more
difficult like I mean it stops you over
me going just here to get a service yeah
and it's really difficult for me to talk
to you in listen to you and get my ear
buzzed at the same time what's the 20
the light it's funny that you remember
some water on my neck you splashed me in
my face you're cutting my ear can you
please just stop asking me so many
questions about what I do for a living
and what I'm gonna do this weekend I'm
really out of it and tired yeah you ever
just feel like that I really go stop
getting my hair done because it was like
my hair was really damaged but I also
just I hated that how long it took and
it gets really expensive and I was like
that's not even worth it mm-hmm let's
just see what how long I can let it go I
said you wanted to do something you
should do something to it I just I
really would like it cut because it's
you know if you let your hair grow out
for it's been I don't know two two years
three years like it's all one length and
it's all really long so it gets like
heavy and kind of borderline like
unmanageable yeah you know like I can't
I can't do any cute Styles other than
like up a down
you feel me dawg yeah your hair is long
it's healthy though it is very help
healthy ass hair dog healthy scalp
healthy hair hope the hair dogs it's
been really nice highly recommended you
know we had a Jasmine Thompson on the
podcast years ago and I was like what's
your secret to long hair and she goes
they just didn't cut it and Here I am
profound his latest word the wisdom
honestly I just stopped cutting it I was
back when we had guests on the podcast
right who are we we can still have
guests on the podcast we just don't know
I know I honestly I like how we have our
podcast but yeah I do remember like
I think we felt like you sort of had to
do it a little bit yeah but like I don't
know I thought honestly if I let my hair
grow out for two or three years without
ever trimming off any part of it like
not even a tram like I haven't trimmed
any split ends like nothing I thought it
would get real ratty and nasty but like
I feel like the really damaged parts
just broke off and then was like we're
fine with this
isn't that like a genetic point where in
your hair stops growing though I don't
think that's how that works I think it
is okay
the mighty you have some people that
have like really really long hair but
then like if someone else were to try
and grow their hair out it stops at a
certain oh you mean yeah I thought you
meant like your hair yeah I mean
everyone has their own limitations to
how they can grow their hair long
yeah we're also but how like the type of
growth like for me like when you're
talking like this is sort of similar but
it's like the beard thing right if I
grow my beard and never cut it ever it
gets to a point where it stops growing
and it just gets ratty ER and like like
more bunched up some people will grow a
Santa beard I can never do that is it
because your hair is like curly no it's
yes like genetics I can't what I'm
saying yeah but it's not just curly it's
like the genetics of how my facial hair
grows it reaches a point where it stops
growing yes yeah that's like you're the
hair on your head it reaches a point
when it stops growing hmm never stops
that's not true you have people in the
Guinness World Book of Records I have
hair much longer if I decide my most
five years old I never want to cut my
hair it's not like it would be out the
door right now it stops at a certain
point it never stops
it's like it's like the I don't know
this part of your hair can't like live
on forever like even if you took really
good care of it I feel like you see
people with hair too like you know yeah
their thighs are their knees like that's
possible but it's not like you're gonna
have a bridal gown of hair if you just
don't cut it a bridal gown with hair
call my bridal gown of hair a band it's
not bridal gown it's hair is a great
band man I don't know I'm kind of
curious how long do you think my hair
would go would you break up with me if I
had hair do take it out of here Harry
would you would you scissor my hair in
my sleep I would never cut it I would
never alter your hair without you
knowing I love how some people think
that's funny
like someone I remember seeing comments
on where someone's like hey Jenny you
should prank Julia by cutting his
mustache off while he's sleeping
first of all when you had a button that
was all the rage people tweeting and
melee cut it happily oh yeah that's
hilarious what if I loved it
but the mustache thing yeah hilarious
joke by the way
how would you even pull that off
literally you're gonna need something
really loud and buzzy to go right in the
front of my face I don't just mean not
in the mean spirit horses yeah how long
do you think that if you grew your hair
out how long do you think your hair
would grow I don't know because your
sister has super long does she how long
yeah sister's hair's like to her middle
back and it's like super thick and dark
like yours
we got good hair jeans are really
healthy yeah I don't know it's for her
yes
what do you not know what your sister
looks like just thought her hair was
just like normal wings no no no no no
she has really good hair ten out of ten
damn ten at ten well yeah because it's
also not like damaged
she doesn't like diet and bleach it and
do all the terrible things to it you
know mm-hmm it's like really healthy
from here to here mm-hmm
really mm-hmm another ten my boy
anyways I might get a haircut soon you
should get a haircut it's been many
years and it's kind of all just really
long well your hair does stop growing as
we just you know discussed at some point
I discussed that it stopped growing you
you said you're not sure well Jenna
thinks your hair stops growing at some
point and I think she's right I'm think
she I think you're right but you know it
doesn't stop just a customer service on
the Squarespace
there's 24 hours a day 365 days in a
year and every single day an hour
they have customer support so when
you're building a website and you don't
know how to build a website or you're
running into a problem they have 24/7
customer support that you can email or
you can live chat it's really helpful so
when you're building a website for you
or your small business or your hobby or
whatever it is and you like I figured I
figure this out but I'm stuck here hop
on the the live chat and they have a
live webinar as well that you can watch
but it makes the process of something
usually so complex very easy and
building a website with Squarespace is
great because they have a lot of really
beautiful templates to make this the the
best-looking website on mobile desktop
and tablets that you could possibly make
with the colors the images the buttons
and the features you want instead of an
online shop within your website is great
honestly you should really try it check
it out go to Squarespace com / - no
Julian save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain squarespace.com
slash engine or click the link on the
low to get started she was like pushing
her head have you noticed me and ease
because me and ease is the most
comfortable wonderful underwear that
I've ever worn and I wear it all the
time they just introduced their new
robes for men and women treat your feet
in their new soft slippers we got the
robe you're not buying this for men in
general
so this holiday season guys cozy up and
you got some underwear onesies or their
new robes their robes are really
comfortable they're the thin micro model
fabric which is three times softer than
cotton which is the same fabric
supersoft that they use for their
underwear and right now you get 15% on
for first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to me undie
stockholm / - no Julian click the link
down in the description to get started
beat about
I love her so we played a game called
life is strange if you don't know what
that is that's fine
if you're doing okay say something go
ahead you remember when Paige was little
and she had one fashion nail so all her
toenails are weight except for one was
black and I just always call it her
fashion you know that whole hand now has
black toenails damn see permanent
pedicure manicure her nails changed
colors how does that happen
no how did you do that did you go to the
salon Patti she's so sweet
you're sweetheart you don't have a
fashion name now girl you got a fashion
hands and without my other hand oh it's
one called black this is boring to
listen to sorry peach you have anything
to say
[Laughter]
anyway we played a game called life is
strange don't know when you're gonna say
spoiler alert
well I yes if I could finish I was gonna
say if you don't know what it is that's
fine it's a story game where you make
choices and it affects how the game goes
there's a lot of different ways you can
go but we played part two which was the
story about two brothers and we finished
it this last week and I just wanted to
talk about it so if this doesn't
interest you or you don't plan on
playing it then you can listen but if
you are gonna play it
spoiler alert so if you if you are gonna
play like a stranger you don't want to
know the ending or whatever may be tuned
out right now because I'm gonna talk
about it and spoil some of it spoil it
for it spoil it spill it
doo-doo-doo-doo okay is everyone gone
okay cool spoil it what were your
thoughts on the way it ended and the
whole season well so we made very
conservative choices
during the entire game morally ethically
tried to do the right thing in
situations too much with our choices are
giving our mother and teaching Daniel
how to be a good person and not use his
powers for evil mm-hmm and at the end we
chose to have them turn themselves in
yes and our chat was pissed at us they
were so mad like a lot of them were
really pissed at us and wanted us to
guns ablaze it across the border and
just gun it but when we were looking at
the alternate endings I think because we
made conservative choices during the
rest of the game about teaching Daniel
how to you know use his powers for good
or evil conservative this may be the
right word I think is just like morally
try to do the right thing yeah
he wouldn't it wouldn't have happened
even the way that people had wanted I
think very yeah very possibly could have
gone horribly yeah well I was scared the
one who's gonna die we've been playing
this game for like a year I'm like I do
not want to watch one of these kids die
like I'm all set thank you yeah because
no matter I know you watched all the
endings I didn't watch all the endings
but I know the gist of what happened but
like the reality is if you're a car
gunning it at the border police like
there's not many cops there like y'all
like y'all dead yeah I'm gonna die well
yeah I heard that in the endings they
don't die or in one of them Shawn dies
right yeah well there's if that's not
not real no well that's a good point it
brings up a good point
right like [ __ ] wheel there's the game
dead well the game has a bit of social
commentary right and so like part of the
storyline and some of the characters are
largely based on like our political
climate right now and how things are and
but and you know what it's like in the
world especially for these two boys in
this fictitious world but also not and
yes the younger brother has powers where
he can like move things with his mind
and he can kind of you know shoo away a
car with his hand very easily like he's
a superhero so there's that which gives
you the aspect of like it's fiction and
it's this like little underdog superhero
story
yes what you were saying if you're if
you're face to face with Border Patrol
police like a fleet of cop cars you know
in front of the border and you start
going you start getting it to the border
while they have their guns drawn like
you you die like the reality is like
that is situation where you know if you
make that choice you're expecting
something bad to happen and the thing is
is like like you said we made I think we
made good choices the whole time which
was kind of hard because like the
choices are not easy sometimes
especially the ones little little things
that make a difference it makes the
noise afterwards and it's like this will
affect your later whatever like those
are not easy and they come at weird
times and you don't know always wants to
do messed-up stuff yeah yeah they do I
mean and like that we kind of played the
first season like that yeah cuz they
peer pressure you they're in there and
they're just like do it do it do it do
it and I'm like oh my god I don't want
to yeah all right fine I'm getting
pressured let's do it I'm gonna do it
just so they can see your reaction and
freak out it's it's like a damned if you
do damned if you don't kind of thing
yeah I mean I was super attached to the
first life is strange I think a lot of
people are and we're and this one
attached me in like a different way
mm-hmm I agree I liked it I agree this
one definitely was a hit different for
me like this one just hit this one for
me I was like in it the whole [ __ ]
time because it's the story about these
brothers right and I have a younger
brother and I always anytime I see a
story about an older younger brother
especially where the dynamic dynamic is
like one of them's looking out for you
the little one you know and it's you
have to protect and say together like
that to me always brings me back to like
my childhood my brother I'm like it hits
me in a certain soft spot and this whole
season I really felt kind of invested in
the brothers in that way and so at the
end it got me really kind of emotional
because it was like it was the the final
moments of like what was gonna happen on
this journey that like you kinda the
whole time weren't paying a lot of
attention to like the details of like
well what's really gonna happen we get
to Mexico like we're gonna go to port
the Lobos it sounds like this wonderful
place
actually you know you don't really sit
down and think about it until it's that
part of the story and then that part of
the story came and it was like super
final you know and the decisions you
have to make are super intense and so
our ending was we'd surrendered and with
the surrender everything went fine no
one liked no one decided to go against
that decision and we go to jail for 15
years and our brother is free the whole
time and we meet him when were out of
jail as adults and it was just emotional
but yeah the if you want to watch the
alternate endings some of them are
[ __ ] [ __ ] man and they [ __ ] me up
like there are some bad endings like
really bad endings bad in what sense bad
in there's an ending where there's the
the worst part of the bad endings for me
and the what makes them bad is that it
ends with strife between the brothers
right like it would be okay if something
bad happened but you went down together
like that's okay to me
because I feel like you're a team and
you're brothers and it's the wolves and
the whole thing but the moment that they
started clashing with each other and
fighting and then those were the final
moments like there was one ending where
you tell Daniel we're not we're not
doing this we're givin up and he throws
the keys out the window and Daniel
conditioned by his previous choices that
whoever was playing made said no we came
all this way we're not doing it for
nothing and then he decides to force the
car through through this like you know
showering of bullets and he's blocking
most of the bulls and he's you know
getting there and they cross the border
and he's like we did it he looks over
and we're dead we got shot in the neck
and we die literally right there in the
car Sean's dead yeah and Daniel's like
crying on Sean's body and that's the
[ __ ] ending dude yeah I would have
lost
that's why chat wants you to make those
choices they want to see some crazy [ __ ]
but then there's another one where you
are like you're the one forcing the car
across and Daniel doesn't want to go
across Daniel wants to surrender so
you're like we're doing a need you're
driving you're driving and Daniel's like
no I don't like this and you're telling
Daniel to use his powers to clear the
wall so he's like crying and he does it
and then literally right before you're
about across the border Daniel jumps out
of the car and he leave
you and then you're in Mexico alone and
he's in America and that's the whole
story
that's just as bad that's not a good
ending it's a horrible ending good oh my
god and then one of the ones that really
rubbed you the wrong way was and
arguably the best ending which a lot of
people have told me is the one where
they end up in part two lobos together
alive and safe right where they both
decide to cross
they both say you know on the same team
the way that one goes is really gnarly
and i think it it made you feel like
they're kind of evil in a way and it
really they did a good job of it because
they look at each other they're like how
does the story end they end is impart to
love us and they both do it and so
daniel slowly walks around the car and
piece by piece just destroys everything
in his path he destroys cop cars he
throws people with his powers and it's
just like a it's like destruction total
destruction like a bad guy would do on a
city full of innocent civilians he's
killing people arguably the cops are
like either unconscious or dead
everything's destroyed and he walks back
into the car and they just drive I think
it's like time to go home it just it
felt wrong and then they end up in
Mexico living their life it doesn't feel
like a great life but people think
that's a great ending I disagree I think
that was the wrong I think that goes
against everything you were doing the
whole time what's the moral of that
story I don't know it's so loaded kill a
bunch of cops and then you can live
happily ever after right like crime yeah
yeah run from the police yeah yeah never
tell the truth yeah and then if you keep
being bad and killing people you'll
you'll get your life that you want
Mexico well I mean while you play the
game you can suspend your reality to an
extent right that's what I respect about
the game is that if you want to play the
game that way to where the ending comes
out that they're the bad guys you can
that's why it's such a rich storytelling
that's why people love life is strange
one in life is strange to some
incredible story telling you it really
can go any number of ways which makes it
so interesting yeah and I don't know I
just to me I I wouldn't want to play the
game that way I agree
I
I play other games that way where they
don't have like emotional and moral
ramifications to me and my well-being
I know Shawn's like older but like
Daniels a little boy like are you not
emotionally invested in him in the
beginning like since all of it since
captain spirit with his [ __ ]
alcoholic dad and you're like I just
want to protect these kids in this game
like it's it's hard for me to play the
game making a decision that I'd like
really put him in harm's yeah even
though it's a video game people's ears
and I respect people for playing it
however they got to I just I didn't want
it wouldn't bring me personally any
enjoyment a game like that yeah and I
think like we might sound insane to some
people who are like this is a video game
what are you guys even talking about
but dude like you guys have ever if
you've ever been invested in a book
movie TV show play whatever the [ __ ]
you've suspended your reality to invest
into something fictional character your
character or group of characters and
events that are not real life but yeah
that's what live estrangement does it
does an incredibly job incredibly good
job of and I what I was gonna say is um
like from the beginning of this season
you know you're rooting for them right
because they're wronged right away they
get their in this horrible position
where they it's like a really
unfortunate spot where their dad dies in
this big accident at where the police
kills their dad right and then he uses
his power that he did know that he know
he had cuz he was just an emotional
nine-year-old and he freaks out use his
power and like the cop dies right and so
then they're on the run but that's okay
see it to me that's where the story
should end like why did any of this
happen and I already saw people in chat
being like Jenna I disagreed I'm like
okay fine whatever but like why didn't
y'all just wait for the police and try
to explain what happened because their
dad got shot in front of them and they
were emotional children I understand he
didn't know he had that power I know but
like why is it your first instinct when
something happens to run from the cops
well I think it says something about cuz
they just watch the cops shoot as that
yeah who's a minority and they're
minorities and it's like a thing you
know it's like it's it's the commentary
part of this game yeah I mean I guess
the I forgot about the way that those it
first of all we played that part of the
game
year ago a year ago it's a little hard
for me to recall it I know that's what's
crazy - it's like you'd play this over a
year cuz we were playing it as it came
out it's like watching a movie and
pieces over a whole year
yeah but that's why you're so invested
because the final part when did it come
out the final part came out December 3rd
so like a week ago but anyway like from
the beginning of the story you know
they're you're just rooting for them and
you and you want them to get to this
like enchanted sort of yeah you hear
them say like our dad is from Puerto
Lagos Mexico he always wanted us to go
back there now he's dead our moms on the
picture what do we do we go to Puerta
Lobos that's where we go we're on the
run and you know in your mind you're
like yeah this is what we need like we
need to get a fresh start and the whole
time you're rooting for them to do that
and then it actually comes to a head at
the border and it's just so heated and
intense and like real feeling even in
this game where it's like this kid has
superpowers it's obviously fake you know
and I thought the dynamic with the mom
was interesting
it wasn't cut and dried she wasn't a
good guy or a bad guy I was it was just
it was a very real life feeling
relationship mm-hmm and I appreciated
that because you know storytelling a lot
relies on cookie cutter characters
sometimes and when you have a character
that doesn't really fit into any of
those molds it feels as real as real
life does sometimes and they did a great
job of that but my favorite characters
in mushroom
mushroom mushroom got [ __ ] up dude
mushroom cot yeah there was man
what a great what a great game just hats
off to the everyone who made that a game
because it's like how do you even it's
like so complicated to think about how
you even make a game like that with all
those choices you're making it like a
such a crazy thing well that's why you
we played it for an entire year so it
probably takes forever to make the whole
thing anyway it's like writing a choose
your own adventure book and then that's
just the first what 1/100 of making it
yeah that's literally just the one
persuading the story and the voice
acting is incredible and the music music
just for the music like if you like good
music yeah it's on what Spotify
everything you type in life is like oh
yeah there's a playlist so good so good
melancholy Hill by the gorillas Natalie
by Malcolm bone so great songs I'm just
like sad I'm sad too I'm in my feelings
I have been ever since we turned off the
game that night like I'm just I'm bummed
I'm like I'm crying crying and I like I
thought about the the whole story and I
thought about how it ended and it just
it just hits man it like really makes
you feel and I like the game I like that
the game takes their time a lot of the
scenes a lot of the conversations and
relationships they're not sped up
they're like slow and they they let
their conversations breathe and they
have moments and it's just I don't know
I appreciated that game a lot and I I
don't recall ever being [ __ ] moved
emotionally by a video game before like
that so I cried at Orion the blind
forest and pretty sure did you oh yeah I
was definitely cried in a video game
before yeah I don't know if I've cried a
video game before it's cuz you only play
a first-person shooter games I cry when
I die
I'm dead I'm just happy for him
my friend died of dehydration yeah well
should play more games the story I we
are we we absolutely are going to be
we're going to be playing Detroit mm-hmm
yeah it comes out that I think the 15th
of this month for PC and I think we'll
start it in January and we're gonna do
like the the long playthrough we'll play
it once a week for a handful of hours
and until we finish our story and what
I've heard from Detroit is that first of
all however emotionally you felt about
life is strange it's the exact same or
more and no and and it's super intense
and the amount of choices is insane
supposedly like you can use there's so
many different ways to play there but
that's what you have mean you're good at
making I'm gonna make in choices I'm
decisive yeah because I'm away all my
options over and over before I decide
which one I want to choose my mind is a
prison uh I'll get to two tattoos spur
of the moment not knowing what I wanted
when I walked into the shop before you
decide what you want for dinner
it's not funny shut up thank you no you
oh it's a nasty boy well I if you care
to try a game like that I can't
encourage it enough I think life is
strange too it's my favorite I think you
can you play on console or anything
there's the only a PC game like okay I
don't know actually like this strange or
like a mobile game there's you should be
able to play it on mobile life is
strange
it's not like a PC console you can
really even yeah it's on ps4 oh it's
awesome yeah so you can play it but yeah
anyway and if any of this gaming talk
first of all if it doesn't interest you
you probably not here so later I'm just
getting to know I mean if we a lien 8
people because we're talking about
gaming and they're not he's not giving
that's fine I understand
well hope to catch you next we'll catch
you next week yeah of course but we we
just finished a game we've been playing
for an entire year basically so yeah and
Italy needed to I needed to get less
soul guys I can't go to therapy and talk
about a video game I feel like that just
would go over well so this is my therapy
for that so thank you for being my my
fellow therapist this is a good use of
your time yeah I wanted to talk about
the several different endings of life is
strange if you wouldn't mind Millennials
and therapy be like but anyway we are we
scream all the time on Twitch and like I
said we'll be starting Detroit pretty
pretty soon so if you have interested I
was playing that well let you guys know
on Twitter and stuff so you won't miss
it but I'm excited I'm excited too it's
nice to play a story game yeah yeah well
that is the end of this episode thank
you guys for listening and hanging out
with us we'll be back we'll be back next
week and then we're taking we're back
next week and then the week after and
we're taking two weeks off for the
holidays yeah we're taking our annual
holiday break in two weeks so you have
this episode too and tomorrow we're
gonna disappear for a little bit nap nap
City nap City Beach
I really hope all of you guys have a
great week and I appreciate you hanging
with us we'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]